hey yo what up wisecrack chris here to
talk about the show that made vampires
cool again
and we're not talking about vampire
diaries tell me something when's the
last time you had something stronger
than a squirrel
instead we're talking about castlevania
now this show is
everything we could have wanted from an
adaptation of the beloved video game
it's a show that effortlessly blends the
source materials lore
what on earth is that ugly thing
i can't believe they hid it
it's the morning star with brilliant
character work and breathtaking
animation
that's right idiot [ __ ] livestock
and to top it all off it's really really
funny
and this got us thinking how did
castlevania manage to succeed whereas so
many previous video game adaptations
have failed
aliens but we gotta deal with aliens too
luigi we're the aliens
we think the biggest reason comes down
to narrative or perhaps the lack thereof
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on how castlevania tells a story
and as always spoilers ahead
to understand what makes castlevania so
great we need to establish the
differences between video game stories
and more traditional narratives like
books
tv and film according to philosophers
john robson and aaron meskin video games
can be classified as
self-involving interactive fictions or
sifs
by this they mean that the story of a
video game is designed to be interacted
with and affected by
the players whereas a movie obviously
won't change no matter how many times
you watch it or what your reaction to it
is
a video game changes based on your
decisions whether you max out stats
or speed run a game how you play is
drastically going to alter
your experience and historically studio
executives have
underestimated how difficult it is to
translate sifs into more traditional
mediums like film
because if you cut out the gameplay and
stick to your cut scenes
how riveting is the underlying story how
much can an audience really identify
with the character
now that they're not actively inhabiting
them and this presents us with the
problem
most video game adaptations face a plot
borrowed from a game but without any of
the game mechanics to make it
interesting
it's why movie adaptations of prince of
persia and assassin's creed fail to grip
us
we're stuck with flat characters
following weak plotlines all of which
results in films that only seem
vaguely related to the original games
but how does castlevania address these
problems
well for starters the show decides to
strip back the plot of the source
material in service of developing the
world and its characters
take the show's first season whereas
castlevania 3 followed trevor
sypha and alucard's journey through
dracula's castle to kill the big bad
himself
season 1 of castlevania does away with
that plotline entirely
in fact the whole first season of the
series has little to do with actually
stopping dracula
after giving us a surprisingly emotional
backstory for why dracula wants to kill
all of humanity
hint they murdered his wife he
disappears for the rest of the season
instead the series pivots to show us the
impact this war is having on one
particular city
aggression dracula went off the deep end
and nighthordes now roam gretchen's
streets
while the city's less than upright
citizens look for innocent scapegoats to
blame
is there a defense effort we don't need
it
we've got a tribe of speakers in the
city once we've done what needs to be
done
the demons will leave us alone while
none of this was in the game this setup
evokes
both the characters and the tone of the
castlevania world the corrupt clergy and
the angry mobs they foment
for example paint a picture of a morally
nuanced world in which no one
vampire or human alike is totally good
argo vista is gone
the other great cities are lost or
losing
gracious will be the last major city in
wallachia
to all intents and purposes i will
be the church and its characters largely
continue this theme
trevor belmont the last son of a famous
vampire hunting family
is a cynical drunk who can't quite give
up on the people his family swore to
protect
him and alucard far from being the
anti-dracula
is kind of like trevor aloof nihilistic
yet unwilling to abandon the world his
human mother loved
and so here i am
choosing to honor my mother by killing
my father even sifa our know-it-all
idealist
must learn to adapt a morally grey point
of view while she learns that the
sleeping hero under gretchen is no
knight in shining armor but alucard
himself
she prioritizes saving trevor over
adhering to the legend
i will incinerate you before your fans
touch that man's throat
i thought i was your legendary savior so
did i
but he saved my life of course all of
this might just seem like good writing
why lean so heavily on the plot of the
original video game when you can
recreate an entirely new story to
emulate the feeling of the game and its
characters
after all detective pikachu and sonic
the hedgehog functionally did the same
thing
discarding much of their original
stories and of course these decisions
were likely motivated by the fact that
stripped of gameplay these stories can't
hold their own weight but
as strange as it might sound we think
castlevania has disregarded the game's
original plot might be motivated by
something more philosophical
by which we mean its guiding commitment
to something called anti-narrative
to understand it we first need to talk
about traditional narrative structure
according to scholars like seymour
chapman every narrative has two levels
story and the discourse the story
chapman explains
is the plot of the narrative the events
that happen in lord of the rings for
example
frodo takes the ring to mordor boom
simple
discourse on the other hand refers to
how the story is told which
if you're jrr tolkien includes literary
techniques such as writing super long
boring songs
keep the glasses crack the plates that's
what bilbo baggins hates
that's what we'll
[Music]
with the vote now we human beings
gravitate towards traditional narrative
and according to scholars like laura
rascaroli
films do everything they can to take
advantage of this fact she writes
the darkness of the auditorium the
comfort of the chair
which induces the spectator to relax and
fantasize the passivity and absence of
movement
inviting a psychic and emotive
participation all of this in service of
making us nod along and buy into the
comfortably predictable narratives on
the screen
but what happens when a plot goes in a
totally unexpected direction
or the discourse just completely breaks
the mold for storytelling
welcome to the anti-narrative according
to robert scholes
anti-narratives are stories that force
us to draw our attention away from the
construction of a narrative meaning
according to our habitual interpretive
processes in doing so
anti-narratives not only force us to
critically reflect on the rules of
traditional storytelling
but they also remind us that stories
themselves are simply told as
codes rather than aspects of human
nature or the world
in other words anti-narratives tend to
break us out of our cinema-induced
stupor
instead forcing us to think about how
the story is being told and how our
brains are
understanding it consider one of the
most drastic anti-narrative films in
recent memory
momento which by virtue of being told
backwards
forces your brain to engage with it in a
very different way
now castlevania has no memento but it
employs a good deal of anti-narrative
while we already touched on how season
one defies expectations by choosing the
forego the whole
let's kill dracula plot multiple plot
lines through multiple seasons similarly
defy our expectations
consider season two for example where
our team actually sets out to kill the
king of night and where we first glimpse
the political machinations of dracula's
court
but instead of being your traditional
proactive antagonist
dracula does a whole lot of well nothing
in fact he does so little to advance the
war against humanity that his
subordinates are actively pissed off at
his apathy
there's no plan dracula doesn't act on
our recommendations he barely listens to
you and hector
we're just thrashing around the country
randomly but even more telling
when trevor and company finally storm
the castle and take on our villain
it's not the epic climax we were
expecting sure it has a hell of a
buildup with amazing set pieces
however the battle doesn't end with a
climactic bang but rather with a whimper
dracula comes to his senses and realizes
that he's killing his own child
please i'm killing a boy
we painted this room we made these
toys it's our boy
lisa your greatest gift to me
and i'm killing him and this leaves
alucard with no other choice but to
slowly walk up to dear old dad and drive
a steak through his heart
it's quiet it's subdued and it totally
subverts our expectations for the
storyline
unless of course you played castlevania
symphony of the night that was a small
battle
it must have been a legendary battle
mostly just desperate and sad of course
this is far from the only example of how
castlevania seems to ensue
our traditional understanding of
narrative in season three we're
introduced to
the judge a harsh but seemingly fair
town magistrate who we grow to
begrudgingly love
but after he nobly sacrifices himself in
a battle against some religious nut jobs
he relays a dirty secret to our heroes
burn my house down
yep the hero that we've grown to love
and root for turned out to be a prolific
child killer it's so over the top and
dark
it's almost as if the show is thumbing
its nose at us he was the judge
and he found his little pleasures like
any good anti-narrative it's forcing us
to re-examine how easily we buy into
traditional hero stories
but castlevania's penchant for
anti-narrative doesn't just force us to
take a good hard look at what narratives
we buy into
it also questions the very idea of
narrative storytelling to begin with
while movies and tv tend to resolve
problems in a satisfying way
real life obviously doesn't play by the
same rules or as our favorite depressed
horse put it closure is a made-up thing
by steven spielberg to sell movie
tickets and castlevania seems to
acknowledge this as well
consider the fourth season in which we
follow count saint-germain's convoluted
plan to bring the love of his life back
from the infinite corridor
you're claiming that the final victory
of the alchemical process is using
arribas to control the infinite corridor
but strangely
we never get any backstory why is this
woman continually running from him
what are her true feelings for him in
the first place while we might expect to
get answers to these questions in a
traditional narrative
castlevania never gives them even on
saint germain's death
all we're given is the cryptic image of
his loved one watching him from the
infinite corridor
the show offers zero closure but the
plot isn't the only place where
castlevania bucks narrative convention
it also makes some sizable departures in
its discourse or
the way the story is told the most
notable one is how the show handles
dialogue
if you listen to any of the hollywood
screenwriting gurus
you'll learn that dialogue should be
kept lean in the words of robert mckee
do not drown your script with endless
dialogue and long speeches
castlevania of course does not stick to
this maxim at all
in fact characters are downright
loquacious
conversations about inappropriate
relations with farm animals can stretch
on for minutes
that was indeed the most swab tale about
sexual congress with livestock that i've
ever heard in these parts
and sometimes characters just talk for
the sake of talking i once observed
decipher belnades that god had quite
gone out of fashion
god is now standing right in front of
you
and soon very very soon
he's going to have sex again the end
result is that we often spend large
chunks of time searching for a narrative
thread in a conversation that is simply
that
people talking it's not about moving the
plot forward so much as showing us a
grounded nuanced depiction of realistic
characters
now i know what some of you might be
saying chris for all this talk of
anti-narrative doesn't castlevania
employ some fairly standard narratives
throughout
and the answer is yes of course it does
the series finale for example
does ultimately give a lot of narrative
closure trevor
ends up surviving his literal fight with
death scifi is pregnant
you know what scared me the most what
then you might end up calling the kid
trevor
after all and alucard has finally found
a person who doesn't want to impale him
i knew you'd be strange but i didn't
think it would be something like this
that brought you back to life
it's always something like this pretty
much as close to a happily ever after
ending as you can get
that being said it would be nearly
impossible to create a tv series that
flips the bird to narrative altogether
if we did that it would never get past
the suits at the studios
but perhaps more importantly this
selective use of anti-narrative seems to
complement castlevania's video game
roots
there's something about a conversation
that drones on for way longer than a
normal scene that evokes the
endless dialogue chains you'd have with
an npc
and there's something about the lack of
closure to saint-germain's story that
makes you think
if you only could have played the tv
show like the game
you could have unpacked more of that
story that if you had the chance as a
player to interact with these characters
you'd dive even deeper into their
already considerably deep psychology
but maybe that's the brilliance of
castlevania's use of anti-narrative
it stops the show from being a carbon
copy of the source material
and in the process it becomes a much
more interesting adaptation
but what do you guys think does the
series strength lie in its willingness
to embrace the anti-narrative
or are we just excited to finally get a
quality video game adaptation
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support
hit that subscribe button like you're
slowly putting a stake through your
vampire dad's heart
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you